[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome the fat man our Batman I'm Kevin
Smith
I'm mark barnard we are here live as
always at the scum and villainy Cantina
on Hollywood Boulevard in Hollywood
California put your hands together so
that the audience knows that you're at
home no Julia well it is the Monday
after justice was served ladies and
gentlemen so we get to talk about
Justice League most of the show but
before we dive into that how have you
been I'm doing well man yeah yeah you
know Thanksgiving preparing you look I
like food
I mean I'm preparing to blow right
through these pants as one does on
Thanksgiving she just get bigger mother
John Travolta I heard once that he's got
two pair of pants on every show the pair
of pants pre-lunch
and post-lunch Wow somebody said at
lunch like one of his things on a rider
once this blew my mind was a bundt cake
so like he always had a bundt cake for
lunch and that's why they had a second
pair of pants I was like the guys living
the life we were coming in from
backstage man here at the scum and
villainy Cantina for those that can't
see the show
wait if you're watching this on YouTube
all right look around you it's like you
can see what it looks like so it's it's
kind of once you're in you're you're in
right you're kind of surrounded by by
the environment [ __ ] we're just down the
hallway before the show got started and
there was a door that like that's where
to keep like the liquor and the closet
and [ __ ] like that and it was just open
a little bit and it totally ruined the
illusion man
this isn't a space bar after all really
man it was like going to the like Mos
Eisley spaceport and then seeing like
the Disney crew backstage shut that door
JC okay let's see what about what have I
been up to I mean I go you been I I want
I saw Justice League twice this weekend
or do I saw once with you on what
Wednesday night yeah and I saw once on
an opening day so I saw it twice but
that was during the week I don't know
what the [ __ ] I did this weekend I
watched The Punisher a little bit yeah
how do you feel
I've watched two episodes I mean I got a
I got a put I got a put aside 11 hours
to be depressed because it is so [ __ ]
sad dude like you know when you watch
that trailer like [ __ ] gotta
kill [ __ ] she's gonna blow up to the
beat of a [ __ ] song from Metallica
and the first two episodes just like is
family they're really dead aren't they
you know it's not like a Spider Man
Uncle Ben thing where he's like awesome
I'll go with great power comes
responsibility where [ __ ] that I'm with
the adventure every [ __ ] scene and
the Punisher ends with him being like
they're gone aren't they and you see
them get gone and you feel this pain
it's a it's about [ __ ] loss behavior
gets better in it never [ __ ] gets
better how many episodes have you seen
I've seen seven it's as look I'm it's
insane
what you've seen savage and I'm still
standing here yeah and you haven't
called a [ __ ] hotline really does it
get any happier No
now it's like perennial sunset man it's
just hopefully it's going down and it's
not to say it's bad it's insanely well
made first episode you get two spoilers
first episode you get to see and [ __ ]
kill somebody with a sledgehammer in the
most interesting of ways so I was like
right on man like they're giving you the
violence but like they're really serving
up the pathos and really leaning into
the yeah man Bambi's mom was [ __ ]
killed like super like in Justice League
you know Batman's kind of over his
parents in this episode you know it was
that last time I was like Martha this
time he barely mentions his parents at
all walks in at the end of the movies
just like let's build a clubhouse here
where they used to but like they haven't
they you know they're like everyone gets
it he's sad he lost his parents we all
understand that [ __ ] this is embracing
of the source material in in a mature
way but a very heartbreaking way it
reminds me of like watching The Thorn
Birds with my mother when I was a kid
the many serials it was just all so sad
I'm like why can't this priest and this
woman be together [ __ ] God because one
of them is gay what is it one of them is
game they were never gonna be together
man that's true well I'm just saying in
real life for a book in real life
Richard Chamberlain he was gay yes sorry
don't tell my mother
cuz I'm relatively sure all while I was
growing up like he was the king of the
miniseries man he was in [ __ ] Shogun
he was in [ __ ] Thorn Birds and my
mother wished he was in [ __ ] her I'm
pretty sure man she was like all that
Richard Chamberlain posed to be like
yeah ma no chance break her heart say
that the Punisher like at the end of
Episode seven has maybe the freakiest
sex thing I've seen in a Marvel show
ever yeah yeah yeah it's spoiled
okay I'm gonna spoil it because why the
[ __ ] not there's a scene where Frank is
breaking into a military compound okay
to in
a high-ranking officer who when she gets
to the house and you sort of peek inside
the room it turns out that he had hired
a dominatrix to go to town on him and so
just before Frank burst through the
window this guy's about to get battery
clips attached to his balls bro wait
what brought to you by Disney battery
what like you know jumper cables
attached to his nuts
yeah which he paid for because it's a
good time and yet they still won't let
them say [ __ ] on the show like
everyone's like frickin bad dude
but meanwhile like it's true they pushed
into the envelope this is a series never
mind [ __ ] jumper cables to somebody's
nuts sponsored by Disney Disney
sponsored the show where a [ __ ] plot
point was an aborted fetus man in
Jessica Jones remember like deep in the
episode in the run I'm watching it
spoiler and then all of a sudden they're
at one point they're like well this
aborted fetus will prove that and I was
like did they just say aborted fetus in
a Disney program we've come so far so
yeah they'll do grown up they'll do
grown up your [ __ ] but they won't let
them say [ __ ] no because that's the end
like that's the line yeah no nudity no
saying the word [ __ ] even though like
anal sex is clearly on the menu
it's definitely implied what in The
Punisher yeah well yeah I mean
get that mic in your [ __ ] mouth right
now up up yeah there you go
hey tired of reading complaints on
Twitter tell mark to put a [ __ ]
market as my swallow it um I will get
back to the Punisher I definitely will
watch it but it's it's about as
depressing as Walking Dead Walking
Dead's not a good time either man like
especially and I'm awakened Baker so I
get up at like 6:00 in the morning I'm
like what am I gonna watch and the
Walking Dead I'm like [ __ ] man
they're still walking like it's never
over yeah yeah there's still [ __ ]
dead and then I try to watch that and I
was like I feel bad for this guy no
wonder he wants to [ __ ] kill
everybody like I think there's more
screen time at a therapy meeting for
veterans than there is in any other one
single thing in the Punisher I thought
that's that's true there's two episodes
I've watched he's both I think I've
watched three halat of time there yeah
yeah because that's a good time
necessary time for sure healing
fundamental but yet on PTSD is that the
the idea of 13 episodes is still too
long at this beginning I think like if
you shrunk it down to an even 10 you're
totally cool and then maybe you don't
have as much chuffa or in this case
chuffa ring with a Montaigne as you
thank you yeah well then alright so I
will get back to that for sure but you
know what I've been watching like I've
[ __ ] binge tit and then I started
watching season 2 which just started
last night you watch search party on TV
I know I should though right it's
[ __ ] clever really clever it's kind
of fun the whole season one is like
Hardy Boys Nancy Drew mystery but like
set in the modern world where nobody
really gives a [ __ ] it's and it's got
alia Shawkat you know [ __ ] maybe from
Arrested Development as the lead really
[ __ ] good but they did something in
their final episode of season one where
you were like are you shittin me
and so season two picks up from that
point and all the sudden season she was
radically different from what season one
was season one was a mystery to season
two is something completely different
really worth watching and something
insanely well written brief is [ __ ] each
one's like twenty three minutes they're
only half-hour mysteries and she has
sold yeah you know what I'm saying
it's well done you know I saw I don't
know who created it I shouldn't know cuz
I watch every episode but I kind of
zipped through the credits was I saw
Michael Showalter his name on it
dude he used to be on the state and he
directed the big sick and he's in I saw
him in an episode so maybe he's produced
it or something like that
totally worth watching and on TBS and
holy [ __ ] dude they get away with
content maybe they bleep it on the
network cuz I buy it on iTunes
but there's the scene the [ __ ] oh my god
man I was like it finally happened they
shot me her Dogma and then years later
and the Metallica comes on and it was
awesome cheers yeah really
what were we talking about before I lost
my [ __ ] my pants bleeping [ __ ] you
bought on iTunes yes there's a scene
between two gay characters where one of
them is LAN search search party where
one of them is like yeah I swallow your
[ __ ] and I was like you could say that on
TBS are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me oh my
god like I want to pitch a show it would
just be called that I swallow your gum
put it right on Front Street and [ __ ]
cartoon TBS the ballsack networked who
knew man was crazy but if the shows
really well written really well done
really well acted I enjoyed it was kind
of a discovery that was a happy like
alternative to the depressing Punisher
which again well made and [ __ ] but I can
only take that much sadness and little
dollars that was not designed for binge
sadness is not a binge watch you know
what I'm saying like you couldn't you
got to do it one at a time if they'd
spread that out weekly I might be able
to handle it better but like you try to
[ __ ] do 13 hours straight of that
dudes life [ __ ] it man did you want to
have a good weekend
[ __ ] you Punisher all right let's dive
back to the subject at hand
Justice League yeah that movie it
happened it happened we saw it we saw it
you all saw it right because we're nerds
if you haven't seen it we're definitely
gonna spoil it and talk about it let's
review it first and then we'll talk
about the aftermath okay I how does one
review this movie I I mean on a scale of
like did you like it or not like it I
liked it I loved it
no did I hate it absolutely not dislike
it No
I think I liked it just fine now as a
big DC fan of course I wanted to [ __ ]
love it and be like it's the greatest
thing that ever [ __ ] happen and you
know expectations were perhaps a little
high or a little too high or something
like that but I liked it is comic-book
movie right up my alley it's got a lot
of things in it that I dug some [ __ ]
that puzzled me but whatever like it's
tough to argue logic in a world where
it's like yeah that guy came from
Krypton you know it's like you got a
throw logic out the window but even in a
world of thrown logic out the window
there's still you know a certain
expectation of how stories are told and
[ __ ] and I realized I gave up the right
to have any expectation on how a story
is told when I made tusks that being
said you know there's certain things
working or watching a movie they're like
well that clearly well we know a lot
about the movie the movie took cover a
little backstory Zack Snyder the third
and the Zack Snyder trilogy which wasn't
really intended to be a trilogy but just
kind of wound up being one Man of Steel
Batman V Superman and now Justice League
at one point Justice League was going to
be two movies and I think you can feel
it all throughout this movie even with
the fixes that this was meant to be part
one setting up a much bigger part two
and then plans changed dramatically so
they had it seemed like it was a movie
where they kept having to play the ball
where it laid you know what I'm saying
like Batman V Superman came out critic
[ __ ] on it
audiences supported it financially but
nobody seemed all that enthused about it
and stuff and the week after they went
out to England or Europe to start
working on Justice League which meant
you know there was really very little
course correction you know you they they
they didn't respond right away to all
that criticism that came later on
according to reports his act got to make
the movie he wanted to make and then in
March of last year they screened it and
decided this is not what we want to take
to market place and as far back as then
is when they start talking to Joss
Whedon about coming in and writing stuff
that turned into directing stuff as that
guide to step away from the project for
personal reasons so going in you know
this is a hybrid film it's not one
directors vision that being said we've
seen it work
on something like rogue one it was not
made by one person it's got clearly the
work of two directors and now we know
the backstory that it was the work of
two directors but it's seamless it
blends and it [ __ ] works and and [ __ ]
they know how to end a movie at the very
least man they [ __ ] just snap on a
lightsaber in the dark and give you a
minute of the best Darth Vader you've
ever seen in your [ __ ] life before
tying up two they were tying right in to
the end of Star Wars so those two
filmmaker mashup that filmmaker mashup
affair worked incredibly well this one
you can definitely see hey that was X
and that was Josh's I couldn't say four
you know I can pick every scene which
was whose but I think there was one that
I was surprised it wasn't oh I read that
the Barry Allen at gin jail when he does
the marker face on the guy in line I was
like well that's clearly just we don't
know who was Zack Snyder so I don't
think it's I I could sit there and tell
you which one was definitely which but
there's huge sections where it's easy to
tell of course we now know because of
Henry Cavill having to wear a mustache
in Paramount's Mission Impossible movie
and paramount pulling the ultimate [ __ ]
card on Warner Brothers who were like we
need him to Reese you for a week they're
like have fun with the moustache because
they he was contractually obligated not
to touch the moustache even though it
would have been [ __ ] 19 bucks to slap
a fake moustache on him Parham I still
dug in and [ __ ] like that and Henry
pettiest of penny oh my god paramount
petty but they you know you got a
respect it's kind of funny so any
somewhere some paramount exactly what
they're like haha we told him he
couldn't shave and instead of like
working around that going alright just
give him a bunch of [ __ ] facial hair
cuz we've done that in the comics that
we saw with him with a beard before the
Man of Steel they decided that they were
going to digitally remove the mustache
this was not private information it was
public information so that meant anyone
who gave a [ __ ] you know who paid
attention that sort of thing
spent most of the movie looking at
Superman go
that's fake not ain't real that's the
uncanny valley because they had to sound
simple shave off the mustache but that's
taking off a layer of image they have to
replace that image and they gave him a
rubbery upper lip and stuff like that so
you know there's that like there are all
these elements at play that you knew
walking in the door there was no way it
was gonna be Avengers
good [ __ ] there was probably no way it
was gonna be Thor the dark world good
you know what I'm saying
that being said what I saw I enjoyed
more than Thor the dark world put that
on a poster there than the shittiest
Thor movie I don't want to like like you
know it's not a Marvel vs. DC thing but
Marvel will always come into the
discussion because they made the
Avengers first they beat you know DC
Warner Brothers had a chance to be the
first superhero team you know movie with
George Miller's Justice League back in
the day and the the strike happened and
the whole thing [ __ ] blew part that
allowed Marvel to go first with the
Avenger to find what a superhero team
movie should look like and be and then
they got to do it again and then they
got to do it on movies that weren't even
Avengers movies were the like the
Captain America is now a team movie as
well like ever in the guardians the
galaxy shows you how to do [ __ ] teams
and that was like what a Hail Mary that
was they took like which hey almost
guardians the galaxy almost seems like
Kevin Feige got drunk in Saigon I was
like dare me to make a [ __ ] movie you
know
and they were like I know what's the
worst Marvel property guards galaxies
like sold [ __ ] and he went and
[ __ ] did it with James Gunn and they
took a movie that shouldn't [ __ ] work
from a comic book property that it like
was never that popular and turned it
into something beautiful and [ __ ]
wonderful so we know it can be done and
unfortunately Marvel will always enter
the discussion when you're talking about
a team movie that all being said I liked
it and I'll go through the things that I
liked and I will be fair and go through
the things that I didn't like so much
these are the things I like no mind you
I'm a DC Comics fan I'm in the bag for
this [ __ ] already I want all this [ __ ]
to be good and so you know you don't
have a high bar with me you just have to
say certain things for example when
Steppenwolf the villain that everybody
[ __ ] hates said the word New Gods
like I was with Marc I went like this I
clutched him you know because I was like
oh my god they in a mainstream movie
something I never imagined I'd her a
year a reference to Jack Kirby's fourth
world the New Gods characters I mean
we're looking at Steppenwolf but you
know didn't have to say New Gods and he
did I was like and then he also said
darkside and I [ __ ] come to my pants
cuz cuz I was like oh my god that's the
first reference sadly the last reference
and you know we never got to see him my
theory just for put a pin in this is
these movies when they were supposed to
be to Steppenwolf was movie one dark
side was movie 2 somewhere along the
lines they decide to remember all the
sudden if you go back and read their
announcement Justice League 1 just as
League 2 then all of a sudden one day
they're like no there's not - it's
always meant to be one like [ __ ] you
said - so they were intending to and
then I think is what smells like a dark
side must have been the second half so
they were like I scrapped it and they
just have Steppenwolf and you know like
Steppenwolf is not a main villain like
of all that [ __ ] grabs Starro the
Conqueror you know why giant [ __ ]
starfish over somebody's face visually
interesting and [ __ ] a weird concept
like why they're fighting a giant
starfish like yeah it controls all of
humanity so if they strike at them or
striking him he could strike back any
man he killed [ __ ] people under his
Starro power and [ __ ] but he's a
starfish he's a star fish from space
[ __ ] like you can make that [ __ ]
work man Steppenwolf was a weird choice
that being said I enjoyed Steppenwolf
because I loved Ciaran Hinds and I could
listen to him [ __ ] he could read my
death warrant and I'd be like beautiful
so well done I know this the villain
looked very generic and stuff but it
that didn't bug me so much I loved his
voice
I was mad not mad if I can disappointed
that and have that line from the trailer
where he's like no protectors here no
Kryptonians no Lantern it's like that
lines not there it's a lot of [ __ ] those
in the trailers remember Alfred like at
the end of one of the trailers looks up
he's like working on a car engine and
he's like thank god you're here let's
hope you're not too late like what
happened to that that don't [ __ ]
exist at all anywhere in the movie
anyway back to the things I liked yes
miss list yes Batman we're going from
the top Batman fights a parademon in the
opening scene of the movie that's
[ __ ] cool never thought I'd see that
in a movie I thought that was cool I
thought was [ __ ] stupid that he
talked to Alfred right in front of the
burglar like he busted a guy and used
that dude as bait and then he was going
Alfred did you hear that like in the
burglars right there if I'm the
like who's [ __ ] Alfred oh my god you
must be Bruce Wayne you know and also he
never arrests the burglar no he left the
burglar exactly like this isn't moving
where people just leave [ __ ] places they
shouldn't leave places yes hey didn't we
have a mother box that's fine it's true
I remember a second time I watched a
movie I was like he just left that bag
up there and I was like maybe he just he
was like wow I used him as bait to catch
the parademon so that'll teach him yes
go get your bag worth of [ __ ] you stole
from that house and that's on your way
he let him take a [ __ ] yeah that wasn't
a very Batman thing but watching Batman
fight a parademon was a cool thing I
never thought I'd see on the big screen
in my lifetime so I was happy to see
that a Wonder Woman saves the kids scene
wonderful I don't like good ones you
know she busts in it's not just kids I
saw a lot of kids but there was adults
there as well but you know it's the
scene you see in the trailer where the
dudes like I'm gonna kill four blocks
for no good reason [ __ ] humanity
everybody's so harsh in this movie like
he tries to blow up four blocks this
random [ __ ] dude and the whole time I
was like just call him something put a
mask on he was a DC character why
couldn't that have been somebody
well whatever that's a small [ __ ] but
it was just like she wonder one comes in
as beautiful [ __ ] like they show the
seconds moving down her fast motion was
more convincing than the flashes I
thought when they showed her and speed
like Speed Thomas it looks [ __ ]
badass she gets rid of the bomb that
explodes and [ __ ] then the villain is
like I [ __ ] it and he just decides to
mow [ __ ] down with a machine gun for
no good reason he's just like well I
couldn't blow up four blocks I'll at
least kill these [ __ ] people in a
courthouse or something like that
and there are children's school girls
who were like [ __ ] screaming like now
and there's an adult who goes Jesus know
and I'm like this is a Super Friends
movie like oh my god it's scary and then
she comes in and [ __ ] that was badass
watching her [ __ ] stop machine guns
with her gauntlets the way that was done
I thought it was cool I read online that
sequence went on longer and they cut it
down God knows why so I liked that scene
a bunch that was fantastic and it played
like a little
Wonder Woman like sequel kind of like we
just watched
in the movies all the sudden you're like
she's back in action
I like that aspect of it all the Aquaman
scenes I loved Allah I thought Aquaman
was grad thought the way my mother
played him was great I thought every
time he was on screen I lit up I was
like this is great what a cool idea
so Aquaman I'm fully on board with that
movie the Great War like when they
showed that flashback scene where
everybody's fighting looks like they
stole her from Lord of the Rings and
[ __ ] like that there's one moment where
they were like you know all the army the
Amazonians the Atlanteans the armies of
man all fought together in the fight
acceptable and then there were like even
aliens from other worlds and they showed
lanterns and then they showed [ __ ]
one like I think it was Steppenwolf kill
a [ __ ] Lantern dude Goes Down and his
hand goes down and then the ring took
off from his [ __ ] hand and shot past
Steppenwolf space I swear to you like
even talking about my like my heart
races bless you em eyes get a little
glassy that was beautiful like if you
could have just done that for two hours
just like it was so like that was
perfect it like everything about that
was beautiful didn't go deep it wasn't
like might you know my kid when that
happened I took my kids see it when that
happened I had to explain it I was like
you don't understand that's when the
lantern falls the Ringo's finds a worthy
successor who is that ring going to and
she is my kid at the end of the movie
goes well I thought Green Lantern was
gonna show up and I was like why and she
was like cuz the ring took off and I was
like that would have been good it was
like I want to see your Justice League
movie but anyway I like that I like
that's I like the ring taken off that
made mine I'm telling you [ __ ] like that
that was worth it for me I paid ten
bucks for that that made me feel like a
kid some people go that's not enough for
me
[ __ ] you that was enough for me Barry
Allen I'm not gonna say the flash
because the flash stuff wasn't that like
it didn't blow me away but all the Barry
Allen stuff Ezra Miller was the comic
relief and played it absolutely
wonderfully it was a joy to watch sadly
I saw every scene almost he did in the
trailers like that they put out in San
Diego
like his whole scene was Bruce Wayne
with the exception of some jokes about
brunch
had been on display and stuff so you
know it would have been nice to discover
him but I get why they put it all in the
trailer like that's what makes people
want to go
I liked cyborgs performance right Fisher
I liked his choice of voice like I
thought it was a cool idea to play him
down here low I liked his character arc
I heard that cut a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
out so there's a lot more missing but I
like I'd he was the character I was
least interested in going in and I
thought they did him justice and I
thought he did him real justice to the
point where I was like I care about so I
bored more than I did going into this
the you know some people bitched about
him saying booyah but that comes from
Teen Titans go if I remember correctly
doesn't it so when he said booyah I was
like and my kids sitting next to me was
like nobody said boo yawn all my life so
one step shy of like that my the
thrilling sequence from him the
highlight of the whole movie oddly
enough didn't include or any of the
[ __ ] heroes that we were there to see
the mother box chase on Thinnes Kiera I
thought like where they were like keep
it moving and the [ __ ] like she
closed the tunnels and they [ __ ]
hammered out the pins and the walls kept
them coming down behind
Hippolyta and then she [ __ ] takes off
and [ __ ] throws the mother box and there
she's like keep it [ __ ] moving and
they're all the it's no it's no heroes
nobody you know just random Amazonians
keeping the [ __ ] mother Box on the
move away from Steppenwolf sequence was
[ __ ] thrilling it was heroic
ultimately spoilers they [ __ ] lose
and he gets the mother box and [ __ ] like
that but it was breathtaking and and I
and it didn't involve any of your major
players but I loved that sequence I
thought it was great and it wasn't just
because I liked Wonder Woman alone I
thought as a standalone sequence in the
movie it was fantastic Meera fighting
Steppenwolf with her aqua Kinesis that
was [ __ ] cool to me because you know
I love the comics is growing up in one
night and just seeing her [ __ ] who I
am and create [ __ ] it and just bend
water and [ __ ] like that brought out the
kid in me when she created a water
bubble for them to talk in I was like so
that's how they're gonna do this [ __ ]
I was like well they got time to figure
that out without having a whole movie
underwater and they have to talk in the
air and alright that's totally totally
but I liked I liked her in the movie and
I like to fight with it with Steppenwolf
Batman save one person's speech love
that we've all seen in the trailers I
felt like there you go that's [ __ ]
Batman right there Aquaman sitting on
the [ __ ] lasso of truth Wonder
Woman's lasso of truth I know that's a
Joss Whedon scene his [ __ ] smells
like one it was a wonderful scene what a
great idea I was like that was so
[ __ ] cool I loved when he was just
like I don't he goes I'll be honest I
don't want to die I'm young I got [ __ ]
to do like that was so [ __ ] well
delivered Superman joins the final
battle some people thought that was
cheesy where he's like I believe in
truth and then they cut to him going I
also believe in justice but you know I
he all he would have had to say is and I
still believe in the American Way and I
would have come unassisted so the fact
that they got to in I know we're not
supposed to say American Way anymore was
Superman it's now just the universal
land ship but like him saying truth and
justice was pretty badass I like that
and then him joining the fight and it
was like his costume in color for the
first time like it's supposed to muted
it was bright blue bright red I like
that Steppenwolf's helmet left behind at
the end of the battle that to me said
that's the first trophy in the Justice
League trophy room so that made me very
excited
sorry I got dry and then the Batman
saying is gonna use the old Wayne Manor
for the Justice League headquarters that
made me happy and then the Luthor scene
at the tag the tag at the end if I'm
sure everybody's staying for the credits
what's his name
Slade Wilson Deathstroke the Terminator
gets on a yacht that belongs to now bald
Lex Luthor Jesse Eisenberg did show back
up and they had this quick scene where
at the gist of it is hey they're
creating of Justice League we should get
a league of their own which I guess is
the injustice league but I would prefer
if he was like we're gonna [ __ ] make
eat their doom and you were like Legion
a dome [ __ ] cuz that name sounds way
better than in Justice League but let's
be honest after this weekend I don't
know if we're getting that movie I
thought they were gonna form a women's
baseball team do you I think that was
the gist that's all the [ __ ] I liked
about that's more than enough to make me
happy and stuff here's the stuff I
didn't like I said Batman talking Alfred
on the roof during the opening that
really ticked me off or I was like why
would he [ __ ] literally say Alfred
out loud in front of anybody even let
alone that guy like how many [ __ ]
Alfred's are this is the age of the
internet like that burglars like hey man
Batman was on a roof and he said Alfred
let me Google Alfred and see what
happens
and you know maybe two days if you're
[ __ ] real bad at it sooner or later
I'll be like it offers the butler of
Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne he's the kind of
guy that could pay for all this bat [ __ ]
I mean he built the Nightcrawler so he
must have money
let's kill Bruce Wayne like that to me
is that's just easy fix
why would he do that well because
everybody in this movie was telling
everybody what their real names were
they did a lot of that Clark yeah wait
what at one point one of the cops here
she called them kal-el too she was a
kal-el of Krypton was like how do you
know his [ __ ] name all that I hate to
say this but all the Martha Kent or Lois
Lane scenes were a real drag to me they
especially opening with she's losing her
farm Christ Almighty like call Bruce
Wayne right now he literally [ __ ]
saved you and he knows your name you
could call him up and be like I'm the
other Martha the living one could he'd
cut you a check but they save that for
the end he's like you know thanks for
paying for my mom's farm now that I'm
alive again [ __ ] could have used it
when I was in the [ __ ] ground the
night crawler this vehicle made no
[ __ ] sense to me whatsoever this felt
like somebody trying to sell a toy if I
ever [ __ ] seen it in the movie makes
no sense no use at one point they have
the sequence for Batman's fighting and
he's got two pair of demons coming out
and he knocks one down knocks another
down he's on his back he goes Alfred I
need the night crawler and
like why why do you need the night crawl
and he jumps in and starts shooting [ __ ]
it was gonna take you 45 minutes to get
there it was so slow everything about
that vehicle made no [ __ ] sense and
what does a spider have to do with a bat
like fun spider-man I'm [ __ ] suing
him because that looked more like a
spider than a bat inspired vehicle to me
how they brought back Superman seem real
dopey to me where they're like let's
sink the mother box in the water like
why couldn't he just have come back
didn't we see it correct me if I'm wrong
the end of [ __ ] Batman V Superman
didn't dirt raise from his grave so it
wasn't that him rising from the grave
like I don't understand like wasn't that
like I thought they'd just find him like
[ __ ] they'd find an empty grave and
he [ __ ] got out himself and he's
wearing a black suit nothing they were
like they had a scene dude bro you saw
them yeah I was right there you were
right there they literally had a scene
where flash and cyborg are digging up a
casket I never imagined I'd see that in
my life like if somebody was like hey
man one day they're gonna make a Justice
League movie I'd be like [ __ ] no
like seriously one of the scenes is
gonna be [ __ ] Barry Allen and cyborg
digging up a coffin and doing it slow
like even though he's the fastest man
alive and he's [ __ ] a robot and [ __ ]
like that they're literally just like
cyborg could turn initiating literally
create a claw just one [ __ ] swoop and
also grave robbing for laughs crazy
they're sitting there digging up [ __ ]
his casket and they bring his casket to
the Kryptonian ship which now figures in
all three of those movies man is steal
Batman V Superman in this one they dip
him back in the water and [ __ ] like they
take him out the box and he's in his
burial suit and stick him under the
water an Aquaman pushes him under and
[ __ ] then they drop a mother box in
there and flash us to run it it real
[ __ ] fast and you know it seems like
a video game not a video game didn't
look like it but the idea of like you
got to touch this [ __ ] before it hits
the water or else you got to go again
that's the boss tank so they did that
she had and then [ __ ] Superman come
back to life and he was a
whose [ __ ] you know not there they
make a Pet Sematary joke which is crazy
and but the audience seem to get it like
I was shocked by that the audience
apparently everyone knows that movie so
there was one moment I really liked that
I forgot it was beautiful they kept
showing flash in flash time everybody
[ __ ] frozen and him just moving
around they didn't do much with the
flash that was very interesting in terms
of fast moving running technology and
sometimes when he ran he looked like
Ezra Miller didn't even know how to run
in real life like in the end scene where
he's like I'm gonna race you Superman I
let go and they [ __ ] cut to him he's
going like sucky ski get so [ __ ] up
so but whenever they free [ __ ] like he
helps Diana at one point like reaches
sword he pushes a sword up to her and
stuff
everyone's frozen and nobody's looking
at him and [ __ ] like that and he's
moving around they have this one
sequence where you know everybody's
holding on to Superman cyborg Batman I
think Wonder Woman Aquaman they're all
trying to [ __ ] hold them down and
flash takes off and he's [ __ ] running
past and he's in his flash time moving
at speed a [ __ ] light everyone's like
a statue and then all of a sudden they
cut the [ __ ] it's Superman and his eyes
shift like he could [ __ ] see him and
they've got to flash and he's like what
the [ __ ] and then they cut to Superman
he literally like turns in the middle of
speed time so like the idea is like you
think you're [ __ ] fast I see you
[ __ ]
like oh that was [ __ ] awesome I love
that to death more that would have been
great
and that was the last thing I didn't
like i said flash is kind of running
looked real weird oh the russian family
what the [ __ ] was that all that i didn't
pay to see no russian family some random
russians unless they turn into kg beasts
or something like that if they tie into
the DC universe but it's like are you
kidding me like i waited my whole life
for a Justice League movie you're gonna
waste five minutes on some randoms like
that like why couldn't those [ __ ]
bugs get in the house how come the
[ __ ] parademons couldn't get in the
house wouldn't that can of bug spray
work why the [ __ ] do I care like
why am I even watching this what about
the rest of Russia and [ __ ] like that
he's the only people we give a [ __ ]
about didn't Boonton have something to
say about all this I didn't understand
why we visited the Russian family all
people online said that it's a Joss
Whedon thing maybe he can explain I
don't understand
and then Batman's costume in the third
act Batman's costume in the third act he
looked like the Michelin Man he
literally came out at one point he had
his helmet off the cowl off and he's
like this he they they don't show him
fighting because he can go to me car and
he drives like but he literally can't
clothes deserves he looks Pat he looks
like the Michelin Man looks like a Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man how many layers
you're gonna put on a guy before you
like alright that's ridiculous let's
take some [ __ ] off when we left so
[ __ ] armored up well yes we were
talking about how in the old days when
boxers used to gain too much weight
their belts would slowly expand to cover
their entire [ __ ] midsection that's
what that suit looks like like just fat
dude who can't quite lose the weight so
you know what I'm gonna put like a tabs
on there he looks heavy
there's times when looks thin but he
wasn't pumping no iron in this one he
wasn't lifting tractor tires he wasn't
CrossFitting remember that and Batman is
you guys all seen where he's like
[ __ ] shirtless and wet yeah it's
pretty [ __ ] hardcore yeah they didn't
have that scene at all he kept his shirt
on the whole movie like me in the shower
okay so that was the [ __ ] I like that
was the [ __ ] I didn't wasn't too fond of
but overall like I liked it
was i thrilled by it there were moments
where I was absolutely [ __ ] thrilled
by it overall though all those good
watch I'd watch it again I saw it twice
I'll buy it and watch a couple [ __ ]
hundred more times until I love it
what do you think okay there's some
stuff I liked I know you don't think I
was gonna say that no I thought the the
dark Superman stuff when he rises from
the grave and beats the [ __ ] out of the
Justice League
was my favorite part of the movie yeah
that would have been cool that was the
whole movie because he'd been the bad
guy if he's this the save one person the
Justice League needs to say B's you have
to save [ __ ] Clark Kent the movie
isn't about anything the movie and and
stopping Stefan Wolfe it's not one of
movies about that's what happens right
it's not there's no I felt like it was
gonna be about grief I felt like it was
gonna be about blame I felt like it was
gonna be about guilt like Bruce Wayne
feels guilty after having all thoroughly
led to Superman's death and so
everything he does in this movie is a
response to that guilt right up to and
including almost killing himself in
nowhereness stand Kyrgyzstan Derka Derka
stand wherever the [ __ ] that was yeah in
Russia he does kind of throw himself in
the harm's way and it is kind of implied
that he feels you know like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about himself he has this
wonderful speech I don't know if it's
wonderful but I've never heard it before
and I never read it in the comic so I
was like that is kind of interesting
where he talked about Superman was more
human than him where he's like thinking
which is ridiculous it's like look
you're the ultimate human also Branagh
has to do his [ __ ] rip you in half
we'll see that for sure but you know
here we go think about it like he found
a life he lived here he found love like
he did a bunch of [ __ ] that Bruce Wayne
hasn't done I thought that was kind of
an interesting notion like that's kind
of cool idea yeah but like coming back
coming out of the grave wrong and I mean
to reckon with Superman on the [ __ ]
rampage like that's fascinating and that
trickles through the entire DC Universe
like if you're gonna set up a Suicide
Squad - then what better engine for that
then oh did you see the second act of
that movie where Superman [ __ ] off and
blew lots of [ __ ] up we need a Suicide
Squad to deal with evil Superman that
was the promise of the first movie but
and it just like that gives it all a
personal heft it gives that our friend
went bad because of us and we have to
fix this all right well don't [ __ ]
write a better movie talk about the one
you saw
we could all write a better movie mark
you know I've the Storrow one was pretty
[ __ ] good but talk about what they
did do I mean most of my problem with
this movie is that they put all of the
right pieces in place hmm and didn't
quite know what to do with them yeah you
know like you're gonna end this movie in
again durka durka Stan and an Aquaman is
integral to this fight you are nowhere
near the [ __ ] water
why not everyone the coast yeah I just
[ __ ] let him [ __ ] him to her own
sperm sharks at people I would watch
that or whales sperm everything that's
true I hadn't even thought about that
there's nowhere near water for that last
fight and [ __ ] I don't know what his
powers are really because he's never in
the [ __ ] water except when he just
swims and saves Rando fishermen guys
Aquaman use your power or he's like I'm
too far from [ __ ] water he's like all
I could do is this I mean even if
they're like Frozone that [ __ ] like when
it's like listen just all I need is a
drink of water just one no just it's
fine just but no he's a half man/half
Atlantean so he don't need the like I
gotta get wet yeah I'm glad they don't
do that
where he's got like a ticking clock
where he's like you gotta get me the
water I gotta get wet we're losing him
like he's not Frosty the [ __ ] Snowman
right you know I love the idea that the
waters all laced with PCP
I like the idea though that he could you
know the idea of Aquaman is he can
withstand the pressures of you know the
depths so up on on surface world nothing
could [ __ ] touch it and so maybe
gravity works like different that's why
it gets those big jumps and [ __ ] like
jumping off the Batmobile I liked when
they show him swimming underwater like
they showed him it's almost like he was
flying they don't try to show him swim
in his arms he just literally flies
underwater I think that's a good idea I
like I like cyborg like I like that
story I like the the man
trapped in the machine story yeah I
thought they handled it well I thought
active apparently there was a lot more
of them I kept expecting for him to be
the last mother box I kept expecting
that there had used the change engine to
fix him but rather than there still
being a box that the box is now cyborg
and so part of this entire last push of
this movie is to save cyborg from from
stuff stop writing a better movie god
damn it
but yes you're right I remember watching
at one point going off [ __ ] he's the
third mother box and they're gonna
[ __ ] tear it out of him and [ __ ] when
stepa Walt's gonna be like he said to
him at one point is that you were born
of her am I gonna be cutting with so
much cool if it was like she's in you
and he [ __ ] tore it out and he was
dying and I had to [ __ ] save cyborg
like that mean I liked your movie but
let's talk about the movie they made
[Laughter]
yeah
there was just too much stuff that
didn't connect with anything else like
you say the Wonder Woman scene is great
it has nothing to do with the rest of
the movie at all we have taken that like
over and over again though honestly like
if they were just like here's a series
of scenes where the Justice League is
just good to people like I would like
that's great like if they just honestly
showed me 19 scenes over in a row of the
heroes and they could just like maybe
each one gets to save three people of
varying lengths little like almost like
Justice League action those little
cartoons they make like I would have
been totally cool with that you don't
have to [ __ ] sew together a plot I
just want to see him saving people and
doing heroic things so moments like that
like thrill me yeah but I kind of want
to plot though I I kind of want a movie
to do with things a movie was just like
with Zack Snyder it's like he makes
beautiful looking frames and [ __ ] just
let him tell these little mini vignettes
and stop trying to cram a [ __ ] plot
onto the [ __ ]
listen the problem is though everybody
wants a plot look he can't ride the bike
so he needs the training wheels he's
really good with the training wheels but
when he does the two-wheel plop thing
he's not so hot he's good it's just you
know he had it here's the thing and I
know you're not done we gotta let you
talk about it but but I feel like he
will he he was his movie was done a
disservice you know what I'm saying like
it's good or bad we should have lived
with his version you know what I'm
saying I've read a piece today online
that was like that's an interesting
theory
where they talked about like at least
Batman V Superman if you didn't like it
it did make money
they said this weird hybrid version
which people could smell a mile away was
trying to be more like a Marvel movie
with the reshoots they said maybe the
audience that was looking for Snyder's
like dark esoteric take on it was like
I'm staying away that's not for me the
other theory of course was that a lot of
people went to see Batman V Superman was
like fool me once and then didn't go
back to this yeah I don't know which
theory is correct I I have a I have a
kind of firm belief that if you that
most of the world has no idea who makes
a movie right here get any amount
nobody knows like if you go to your
average mall anywhere if you have any
average library school whatever anywhere
that's not in New York and LA in maybe
Chicago and ask them who directed any
[ __ ] move who directed et they could
not tell you who that was are you your
[ __ ] high
everybody knows Stevens but my mother
knows that [ __ ] like and she's not
well-versed she's not like I could tell
you who directed the Cannonball Run like
I mean how neat him ya know but I I
honestly don't think that enough people
know that Zack Snyder directed it and
care that he directed it that didn't
show up because it wasn't a full Zack
Snyder vision to knock it 70 million off
of the gross fair enough I can't argue
with that you know like I think that I
could but I won't
I mean I I think that but yes there was
a compromised vision in this movie hmm
part of the problem is with all these
movies is that there is no vision at
work is that that Zack Snyder it seems
like they need a Kevin Feige they need
they need somebody to stand over
everything and look at it and say here's
what works for us here's what doesn't
here's here's what fuels this particular
machine and here's what doesn't here's
the [ __ ] that diehard fans will love but
won't help us in any way here's the way
we need to change this origin to have it
make sense to the person who doesn't
know that Zack Snyder directed it and
here's what we need to keep that's
integral to these characters I think we
the audience hurt this movie to be
honest with you because after Batman V
Superman there was a lot of they should
have done this and they should have done
this a lot of armchair quarterbacking
Monday morning quarterbacking we need
the audience but the I think they
started listening because it seems like
any [ __ ] issue you had about BBS they
addressed in this movie like a lot of
people were like two and a half hours go
[ __ ] yourself this one was only two
hours it's also dark go [ __ ] yourself
this one had lots of jokes in it it
seemed like they listened like Batman
hates Superman what the [ __ ] is that
now Batman's kind of in love with the
Superman
you know where's like I don't not like
you you know I mean it feels like they
listened and fix the somewhat
superficial things that you could do but
not the endemic issues that it has which
is I don't understand why these
characters do the things that they do I
don't understand why these people are
heroes I don't understand what makes
Superman Superman so that when you see
him on screen you're not entirely sure
why I mean this is the closest that I've
gotten to seeing the Superman I remember
you know like once he comes out of his
pet sematary trance he's he's glorious
and he's hopeful and he believes and
once you look at his lip real close then
he's a monster from another planet but
he's an alien
you know like I think that that there's
they're rushing to keep up there in a
reactionary place and of course it's
always unfair to compare Marvel to DC
because there are two very different
universes with two very different sort
of plans of attack but they're playing
in the same field so you kind of have to
compare them in a way yeah
and DC is reacting to what Marvel did as
opposed to doing what they could do best
and until they figure out what that is
until they figure how to synthesize the
things that make DC special yeah then
then I think they're always going to be
playing catch-up I think that last scene
with the Terminator and Lex Luthor is a
if they get to keep going is a good
direction to go ins just embrace it lean
into the characters like just make more
do something that people haven't done
before like you know I would I'd say
Warner Brothers DC started this [ __ ]
years ago with [ __ ] Superman hey or Z
what a superhero movie looks like kids
and then redefined it themselves ten
years later when they did Batman with
Tim Burton hey this is what a superhero
movie looks like isn't there's dominance
for years and then I guess the first
one's kind of like go hey here's what a
superhero movie could look like was Fox
with the x-men you know okay this is
different and so that changed the game a
little bit and they came along strong at
a time when DC movies were kind of on
their weaker end then you know Spiderman
defines what a [ __ ] comic-book movie
could be and should be you know and
[ __ ] the bars moved and then Chris
Nolan comes to Batman and redefines what
a comic book movie could and should and
suddenly DC has the ball again it's like
holy [ __ ] and then at the you know right
in the middle of it while we were all
loving on the the Joker so hard Heath
Ledger's Joker something quiet began a
little revolution Ironman happened that
same summer and suddenly what we would
come to think as a comic-book movie come
to think of as a common who's redefined
forever and the market dominance that
Marvel holds has everything to do with
that starts with Ironman they continue
telling great stories and they continue
telling different [ __ ] stories now
Fox has given them a bit of
for their money lately by finding a new
area to tell comic-book stories and
going this is what a superhero movie
looks like now a lot of Deadpool a la
Logan Warner Brothers needs to [ __ ]
find their place again they need to be
like this is what a [ __ ] comic book
movie looks like now and I with all due
respect they've tried three times with
with a vision that like a lot of people
don't seem to go for they like to here
is a little more hopeful little more
happy or whatever the [ __ ] but I respect
what he's done over those three movies
and I think we get some time away when
you were able to watch all those three
in one sitting you're gonna see a vision
particularly if they put out his I think
they owe it to Zack Snyder to put out
his uncut version like look I'll [ __ ]
pay three times like charged me for the
one I saw I'll buy that on [ __ ] video
charge me for like the [ __ ] the the
all Zack Snyder version I'll buy that
[ __ ] again and then charge me for like
hey [ __ ] this is the eighth
version of the Terminator you're buying
it again like I'll buy it it's got a
special box like I'll buy it comes in a
mother box I'll buy it I hope they take
my marketing ideas so here's my theory I
feel like I'm gonna draw an analogy here
okay DC so [ __ ] funny how serious we
talk about this as if it's like North
Korea or something like that but when
there's a big deal wait for this analogy
okay DC is the dude with a giant dick
who has no idea how to use it I can't
relate to this at all Marvel is the guy
you know soso dick but it's done the
[ __ ] work that I get Marvel came to
movies especially with the cinematic
universe with none of their big guns
that's true that no spider-man they had
no x-men they no daredevil all they had
was a bunch of dudes that nobody gave a
[ __ ] about they had a loser man like we
love Iron Man now but [ __ ] I remember
when they announced that movie even I
was like wow they had a roster of like
b-string heroes and they had to work to
make us care and they put in the work
they absolutely built this [ __ ] story
of like soap opera intrigue and who's
gonna do this and what's happening with
this and holy [ __ ] is that oh my god
this happened that I bet man I've
happened they built that city with rock
and
you're getting out DC was like look at
this [ __ ] dick its Batman it's one or
minutes I have everybody I've ever
wanted it should be enough for me to
just show you this dick if I just put
these characters on screen I don't think
we're on the political climate for this
analogy anymore roll with me if I don't
know if I want to if I just put these
characters on screen that should be
enough yeah I agree that's not enough
like it was like the marketing when he
looked at the billboard and I think I
said this before I don't think this is
Monday morning quarterbacking I might
have not said it here might I set it on
another show but you look at the
billboard it's literally like there they
are look at how [ __ ] heroes there are
heroes look at your heroes that was it
there was no like hey what's the story
about like what do you care heroes but
Thor ragnaroks billboards like literally
told you a story we're like only [ __ ]
I'm going to that like there's something
going on a guy hates that guys the
Hulk's in it there's a bunch of [ __ ]
happening it just felt like even they
try to tell a story with their marketing
materials where this I mean it so for me
so much of this movie was just look at
the people we put on the screen look at
how awesome this scene with Aquaman is
look at how awesome this thing with
Wonder Woman is look at how awesome this
bit with a Nightcrawler is sure alright
whatever nobody said that because I
spent 40 million dollars making that
[ __ ] Nightcrawler move and they're
like no this is great
so like I just think they need to do the
work and realize that that even though
they don't have the limitations of not
getting their heavy hitters the way
Marvel has and so they compensated for
it and just gave you story that
captivated you yeah you can get to the
end of a movie where it's two dudes
punching each other and that is far more
resonant and moving and emotional then
we just destroyed you crania maybe or we
saved it but now the flowers are weird
and this family that's really the dog
and I'm in an Independence Day movie
that just doesn't get blown up by well
afire gets saved so we give a [ __ ] they
did grow flowers out of those weird
apakah and they never said apocalypse
like while she was telling the story
she's like he wants it to look like his
homeworld and I'm like just say it one
more word well did they have a test
screening and somebody was
I don't get it that's true religious
like why take that out why not just say
the word well I say dark side once it
was weird it felt like those worse ops
not to me personally but people like me
who are like as one hear him say new
gods and like New Gods I'm like I'm done
yeah like it it feels as if all too
often in these in Marvel movies they're
listening to Bruce Wayne's advice save
one person and then maybe save another
one in in in Winter Soldier you're
saving Bucky you know in in Logans Civil
War it's like we're saving we're saving
rounds emo ultimately you know like
we're weird it's personal and it's small
the world doesn't have to be on fire all
the time and it feels as if DC is all
about like apocalypse as opposed to just
make me care and until they do that then
I feel like there's gonna be a lot of
look it's a thing that I loved when I
was a kid moving that's enough for me
oh my god that'll do it for me but I
mean if you look at the box-office it's
not enough for enough well let's talk
about that look now you talk about that
Holly you you chew the box-office for
this let's talk about Batman V Superman
was was opening weekend uh 166 million
dollars Jesus that's a lot of money
Suicide Squad 123 both movies critically
derided yes
didn't matter [ __ ] people still
showed up Wonder Woman's opening weekend
a hundred and six million dollars okay
opening week out of Justice League was
projected it was presenting then over
the weekend it came in at 96 and then
kept on revising downwards until today
it's 93 can you imagine there's a world
where 93 is not successful like how do
you win and lose at the same time
I mean and the problem is is that you
know this was supposed to be I'll never
make a movie that makes ninety-three
million dollars but this whole I don't
think all my movies together made
ninety-three million dollars like that's
a number that I aspire to and that in
some for some reason Warner Brothers is
like we're sad today I mean it's only
really sad in comparison because know
what those other numbers in comparison
to Avengers which when not opened and
again it was with gala heroes together
in the same screen and we're gonna show
you them just hanging out doing stuff
well it open to two hundred million
dollars
first one out the gate they look look at
all these heroes look at him look at
them together look at them they're
looking at you yeah that'll do that's
excitement but if you're gonna do that
again you got to figure out ways to
recreate it know has anybody open to two
hundred million since then force
awakened Wow it's [ __ ] starved it's
any superhero movies yeah I mean that's
you're gonna have to do something
[ __ ] incredibly special to ring that
Bell again that's the benefit of being
first out of the gate and then age of
Ultron makes 191 million dollars the
second time you see that 93 we have to
do a side story and this is weird I'm
not being political but government's
suing [ __ ] Warner Brothers right now
the Department of Justice just announced
it I think over some AT&T mergers
there's gonna be a merger between Warner
Brothers and AT&T when Department of
Justice is suing to stop the mergers
eighty-five billion dollar merger the
idea being it would be too big for the
company some people think it's fueled by
the Trump hate CNN and blah blah blah
so leaving politics aside that's a very
real situation right now that affects
Warner Brothers in a big bad way they
were about to merge oh my god all the
money is theirs they've got all the
money in the world all that's at AT&T
money at you but if the government shuts
down the merger they will have to look
long and hard at what movies they're
going to make in the future Aquaman is
done and for all intents purposes the
word is it's very good you know they're
gonna make another Wonder Woman movie
they've already announced it and why
wouldn't they that's a sure [ __ ]
thing they've announced Shazam and
they've cast Shazam so
it's in the works but everything else
from there on in is like it's like who
knows what happens they may after this
weekend just be like you know what we're
gonna [ __ ] do standalone movies like
we used to we're not building universes
[ __ ] all this I don't know what their
reactions gonna be do you think people
get fired
I mean people probably should whoo
that's cold I mean I wasn't asking that
asking do you think it'll happen just
like that this creative vision isn't
working the audience is responding to
what the critics are responding to it
the finances don't make sense anymore
and the only way you fix that is by
changing the people who are making those
decisions now will they that's another
[ __ ] question because Hollywood is
loath to get rid of anybody for anything
that's not true they got rid of me a
long time ago but yeah I think I think
there has to be a course correction
there has to be some kind of reset and
ironically like flash flashpoint gives
you the opportunity for that reset or
crisis gives you the opportunity for
that reset well they should lean into
the flash but I mean I know they've had
a hard [ __ ] time putting the flash
movie together but now that you see that
that element could work like give Ezra
Miller a flashpoint movie that's there
you go that's an exact way to correct
your entire DC you know I mean what DC
has a Marvel does and a great story a
warm story a story about a child's love
for a parent gone wrong and [ __ ] like
that like there's real heart to that
story and it plays with time and
throughout the DC Universe you do a lot
of [ __ ] cool things with that I mean
and they have a multiverse Marvel
doesn't have a multiverse there's a
world in which if you do a crisis story
then you can have Michael Keaton
Christian Bale digital at Adam West you
can have all of these [ __ ] Batman's
together
stop making better movies than these
[ __ ] people oh my god you need to be
in charge what a good [ __ ] idea I can
pick I'll show you [ __ ] everybody's mind
though like guess what [ __ ] Marvel we're
connecting all the movies Michael Keaton
exists with [ __ ] Ben Affleck with
George Clooney
Oh that'd be [ __ ] badass and you
convinced them all to do it and they all
come back and the ones that don't I mean
if we can do a half-assed [ __ ]
digital mustache removal on cattle if
you spend the time and really [ __ ] do
it then yeah you get Adam West back that
would be amazing do you know and then
you could capture so many generations
because you can go all the way back to
like the Christopher Reeve Superman
universe absolutely so that's oh wow you
could grab the TV universe you can make
a fuck-off two-hour movie where most of
the world would be like what's happening
it's like every movie I've ever seen and
it's kind of what it is man ooh that's
hot and then you come out of that and
you pick the ones you want you want to
recast been fine we didn't want that
anyway he wants to recast been okay for
every article you read he's talking
about a graceful exit after two times
playing the role guy
is hard man that's hard like Robert
Downey jr. been doing that [ __ ] 10 years
as Iron Man you don't hear him going I
got to get out of this [ __ ] he's like oh
my god it gets easier the older I get
now I just sit in a room and in the
helmet and that's it like a [ __ ] the
rest is CGI it wasn't gonna pay me for
homecoming [ __ ] yeah I'll do that yeah
oh my god oh no why he's trying to leave
but he is he doesn't seem to have had a
good time as it was run as Batman I mean
if God as you surmised once that he as
an actor wants to be liked
and part of the reason why he takes
Batman is to be on the biggest stage in
the world to rehabilitate his superhero
legacy to be a hero and to be liked by
millions of people and sad Fleck wants
proved that this dude is not being liked
by as many people as he wants it it's
not universal praise the way it was for
Christian Bale did people universally
praised Christian I think I think by
Dark Knight yeah I'm trying to think how
I feel about the Bale performance but it
wasn't oh god what did you do to my bat
no no not at all it was very in keeping
with the character and stuff I had
little problems like for example
Christian Bale has the thing right here
by his eye so did Batman so anybody that
knows [ __ ] Bruce Wayne it's like hey
you've got a thing like Bruce Wayne
Pam may be [ __ ] tell right there but I
liked his performance but you know he
did have the unfortunate voice to deal
with at least he'd show he made a choice
but the choice where I got that's kind
of hard to watch it's the addition of
the voice to bend that sounded kind of
cool yeah made it sound hopeful going
forward they do that so that no poor no
Wagner ever has to make the choice no I
got this listen we're drag art and no
one's like yeah go ahead you've got it
well if you had to give a letter grade
to the movie I would give it a b-minus
you I give it a C I get a C I don't
think it's I don't think it's a disaster
I agree I think there's a lot of reviews
that were like there's a [ __ ] train
wreck I think it was a train now there's
there's pleasures to be found you know
there's there's momentary moments of way
dirtier than it needs to be pleasures to
be found here on Fantasy Island but it's
uh it's uneven at best you know as Shep
said wet clay you know Jon Schnepp said
that on Twitter yeah pieces of it did
work but it's still wet it's not molded
yet it's not solid yet it won't support
everything they needed to support do you
think they make another Justice League
movie now that it's opened at 93 million
do you think they're like [ __ ] it we're
pock committed let's do it again I think
you double down on this [ __ ] I think if
they do it's 10 years from now
really so what about that last scene we
were [ __ ] told there's gonna be an
injustice gang you don't think we're
gonna get it
you think they lied to us in the
marketing I think we get that in Man of
Steel - I think that they you know what
they owe him his own movie because it
was on a [ __ ] roll he should add Man
of Steel - but then BBS and then Justice
League so they should give Superman his
own movie and they should do a Man of
Steel - and they could do injustice gang
but I'd much rather than do Brainiac
that'd be [ __ ] cool but who knows if
we even get another one it might be a
while before we see some of the big guns
again I'm I'm even curious what happens
well I mean Matt Reeves Batman
must be next and they got to keep that
[ __ ] going even when Batman dies they
pull out the paddles and like clear
because like they [ __ ] need him in a
big bad way so there'll be he'll be back
sooner than you know it's like yeah I
think we waited well for Justice League
that's my guess
all right let's move on from Justice
League talk about something else
what else is going a Harley Quinn TV
show ooh that's good yes what do you
mean animal show oh one of those
animation is doing it for the new DC
all-access app or whatever they're
calling it's for the app yeah so it'll
sit alongside Titans and they got my
money I'm a'ready to I'm ready to get it
all ready that's [ __ ] tremendous man
there's a guy who does effects for flash
and Supergirl arm and arm and Kevorkian
and he's working on he's working on the
Teen Titans show and he sent me a text
this week on you were gonna [ __ ] love
the Robin outfit yeah it looks cool he
says I'm looking forward to that Teen
Titans show but now I'm looking way
forward to this Harley Quinn thing
that's a good idea
[ __ ] that took a long time who's in
charge of it please say Bruce Timm and
or Paul Dini
Sam register will doesn't sound like
Bruce Timm or not but he's been around
the Warner Brothers animation since the
the animated series Batman animators oh
really
yeah Sam register and what has he worked
on all of the things that I've had capes
and Ben cartoons the Warner Brothers
that's cool but it's being overseen by
the guys who did powerless on NBC last
season the sort of DC Universe sitcom
yeah the one that got canceled yes so
wait the reward is here's a Harley Quinn
show [ __ ] I want to fail like that
Hollywood I guess good for them man
apparently that show is fun sadly it
didn't it got canceled way too quickly
yeah and they are going after Margot
Robbie to reprise her role oh in the
cartoon yeah why not like it'll take her
like [ __ ] ten minutes to run in and
[ __ ] throw the boys - you don't even
have to put on any real clothes you
could go just like in her pajamas that's
the beauty of cartoons you just [ __ ]
sitting there recording the boys off the
glam up or any
thing I would do it if I was her she's
probably I don't need the money [ __ ] you
we all need the money you should do if I
was their age and I was like [ __ ] do
it
why not I've done all in this [ __ ] I
gotta worship for the money [ __ ] yeah
but also it's just like lock it all up
make yourself like as associated with
this characters popular [ __ ] insanely
popular so I'd say do the voice I think
that's a good idea
Fox is making a multiple man movie what
yeah Jamie madrix is getting his own
movie uh-huh he [ __ ] [ __ ] I am not
[ __ ] [ __ ] why I mean I'm all for
it but why how did this [ __ ] it happen
lose a bet what's going on because James
Franco wants to play him oh really
that's why it's happening that's
actually a good [ __ ] idea holy [ __ ]
oh my god that's one of those like you
say a name and then you say another name
and you're like yeah that's cool idea I
would watch him play that Simon Kinberg
is producing and Allan Heinberg who
wrote Wonder Woman is writing it I'd be
a cool idea for you know he's that he
could turn himself into multiple
versions of himself
it's like multiplicity but in the
superhero universe that's cool I'll see
that in a heartbeat good idea I like him
he's interesting as [ __ ] I can't wait to
see the disaster artist so I'm game to
see this James that James Franco that
James Franco
can you imagine have that much power
where you're like I think I want to play
the multiple Man and the like did you
[ __ ] hear that mom or past him right
now give me the standard rich and famous
contract that's good that's good for me
I like that idea that's cool yeah man
Marvel Comics has a new boss the actual
comic book the actual comic book company
axel Alonso had been the editor-in-chief
axel was my editor-in-chief on
spider-man buck wonderful guy yeah very
sweet guy where'd he go unclear he's
just leaving Marvin he's leaving Marvel
he hasn't and that's what his next thing
is how does it double hit tomorrow first
they lose Bendis last week now they lose
Axel's yeah what's going on I think that
they're undergoing their own little
creative reset at least on the comic
book front Wow
and CB Cebulski who had been a CB yeah
he'd been SVP of like talent relations
and he was playing poker with him as
well recently in China overseeing a lot
of their Asian initiatives is not coming
back to run the comics it's a big job
for him but he's a big guy so he's got
this it's nice that we talk about comic
books I've seen a lot of people on
Twitter be like wow you're talking about
comic books you're fat piece of [ __ ] I'm
like we will the other thing they make
they that people get very mad I took a
lot of [ __ ] this week on Twitter gone
just change the name to fat man on
Marvel you [ __ ] traitor it's because
we don't talk about Batman enough and so
I think we have to institute a weekly
Batman category I mean the show is
called fat man I'm Batman so I think
maybe one like every week here's the
Batman category this week clearly it was
Justice League so we don't have to
[ __ ] go any further than that but
every moving forward we should people
are starting to get shitty about the
past we don't talk about Batman enough
but honestly I think that has a lot to
do with the fact like when I started the
show it was post Nolan and I was in love
with his version of the character and in
love with the character again it
reminded me of everything that I'd
always loved about Batman and stuff and
so it was a great time to start talking
about it and these few versions that
they've been doing the last two I knew I
liked this version of Batman but it's
very awful he looks great but he's kind
of off character in a lot of ways and
stuff at least in the last one with him
being so kilee
so it's it's it's been I don't know is
it it's I've got to reconnect with my
love of the character that's my fault
all right we'll do it yeah you want it
we'll do it we'll get I don't give a
[ __ ] thanks mark is that all the news we
got that's all the news we got all right
what else we got going on we have
special guests today okay I went last
week to go see the premiere of Marvel's
runaways how was it I really really
liked it I'm
a little bit out of touch with the comic
book I read the first like 20 of bran
Kevin and Adrienne I'll phone is run
these were a bunch of kids find out that
their parents are like super villains
yeah
like you know it's it's very much like
you know OC meets drug in Legion of Doom
where you realize that oh [ __ ] my dad is
a super villain oh [ __ ] they're killing
people in the basement oh [ __ ] we have a
dragon yeah so it's it's the humor is
really there the characters are really
strong the cast I got for this is really
smart and and I ran into this dude who
was like hey I've been a comic book nerd
since I've been like 11 I love that man
and I'm in [ __ ] Runaways I am I am
the taller thinner handsomer version of
you and I said well and we should stay
inside aside so I can feel absolutely
horrible about myself in front of other
people
so yeah Ryan sins is in the house who
plays come on all the way down the other
side
now you got the long walk mark we'll
fill it in the walk three long walk see
ya Ryan was like man I love it you
should come to the premiere I said I
would love to come to the ramier and he
says I'm I'm a fan of the podcast you
should come on the [ __ ] pockets we
got a show to promote and like I said I
need to feel worse about myself so give
it up for Ryan everybody thank you thank
you it is a pleasure to be here
this cool place it's not kid oh yeah oh
yeah Star Wars is like why I'm in LA
right now why when I saw Star Wars as a
kid I knew I wanted to be an actor that
was it like the lightsaber came up and
it was a wrap so all these years later
I'm here standing with you guys I made
it
if this is making it you didn't make it
very far and went ahead with my favorite
childhood cereal right here Frankie yeah
but I came bearing a gift okay I knew a
safe gift for you mark I need some info
and you got an original coming but this
gift was birthed while listening to fat
man on Batman a couple of years ago oh
my god so it's a mash-up of about ten or
so of Batman did you draw this I did you
draw as well I do look at that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] awesome how long you been
on the graphic artist [ __ ] man this is
unfair to be able to do two things you
can draw an act that's wrong you know a
little nerdy kid drawing my comic books
I learned Anatomy by studying John Byrne
and Neal Adams and Jim Aparo and Sal and
John Buscemi yeah yeah yeah so you know
that was what I did and I kind of left
it alone I hit a little growth spurt in
high school started chasing the
basketball around and then I finally I
saw love Jones in 97 and realized that I
wanted to be an actor that was the dream
that I had suppressed all these years
and I just just you know pursued that
with everything I had and uh like few
years ago I'm like oh yeah I can draw so
I started just started rediscovered it
and man it has been a life saver
good to be able to turn to something
creative particularly in this business
because there's this business is full of
rejection when you get the gig you're
like [ __ ] is amazing but that happens
regularly and well more often than not
somebody's usually telling you know in
one way or another and so it's nice to
be able to turn to something creative
when there's some negativity over here
like rather than concentrate on like oh
she didn't work it you can be like this
I'm in control of this I created some
art this exists now and it makes you
feel better just being creative in the
first place nice to have that to be able
to pivot to but clearly getting the job
at your problem right when did you get
the gig when did that happen how did
that hand early this year we shot the
pilot in around February and I got the
the audition and you know you don't get
a lot of details it's like this untitled
Marvel project but then once I read the
breakdown my wait a minute wait wait
wait parents kids and and to be honest
like I didn't read Runaways I kind of
left my comic comic book fandom kind of
in the late 80s early 90s and then when
I tried to come back I think the the art
style was so abrupt and then I'd missed
so much that it was just too hard oh my
god I was a stick to the cartoons like
everybody has that weird moment for me
was also in like the the mid nineties
late 90s where I just broke up with
comics for a while yeah I think it was
the the x-men extinction agenda or
whatever the [ __ ] that was we're like 19
different covers and 48 different
crossover issues and it was just too
much like I'm broken I'm young and I'm
trying to date somebody I can't spend
all my money on [ __ ] comic books and
you step away from it but but what what
pulled you back into it after that time
um well okay so well it really it was
like the finding out there was a Marvel
unlimited app where I can go back and
catch up stuff but so when the audition
came in once I saw the breakdown sounds
like that Runaways thing so I opened the
app and like I'm flipping and as soon as
I saw Jeffery Wilder the character that
I play man I just started laughing no
okay I think I could I could yeah big
black I just got to get the lines right
you know but yeah it was it was just the
the audition process was a little
we got a great cast and director Patrick
Rush is super super great at what he
does but it was nerve-racking the closer
I got because how long was the whole
process from the moment you heard about
it to the moment you got cast it's a few
weeks I guess you had the shock living
the uncertainty where you're like I
don't know I think and people like how
to go and you're like well I think it
went well
I left the screen test I called my
mother and she didn't pick up and when
she didn't pick up I say okay you know
what I'm not saying anything to anybody
about this and then then when it came
and I got Jeff lobe on the phone and he
welcomes me to Marvel I just saw like it
was like yeah okay thank you thank you
Jeff this is really cool man
got off the phone and just yeah just
nerd it out so that's right that Jeff
would oversee that even though it's at
Hulu as opposed to Netflix or as opposed
to ABC they spread their [ __ ] out over a
couple of different networks Lee's point
so this is their first to lose show is
it all up yet did they put it all up so
that I well it the official where they
do their yeah well we're we're dropping
the first three and then as weekly after
that but the official date is tomorrow
the 21st is the 21st on the East Coast
now so I think they're the episodes are
available now on Hulu for us fantastic
do you get to watch them all no just
just just the pilot they show you that
yeah
did you see other stuff like if you when
you go in and like loop or anything like
that
yeah man so I had my first ADR session
no no it was my second ADR session a
couple of weeks ago and they
me to do the you know do a previously on
Marvel's runaways and so yeah that's
they like can you say that yeah I think
I don't think we're all doing it
everyone gets to do and so I got my
headphones on and I'm looking at the
screen I'm like okay alright and I look
up and I see the Marvel intro or the red
screen now just like hold on take it
back take it back let me do it again do
it again let me get myself together here
so it was like wow this is really
happening this is really happening what
is it like being a part of the Marvel
Universe but for you for a while you've
been a spectator a fan back in the day
and then watching the movies or the TV
shows I imagine and then suddenly like
you say you get the call from Jeff elope
and like you're part of it you're part
of the fraternity sorority of something
so a very special Club it's surreal it
really is I mean especially to to work
on something that that I would watch if
I wasn't on it you know so it's it makes
the the long day's like just just go by
you know and and I hope and pray that
this never this feeling never leaves
because it is truly you know behind my
desk when I'm drawing and or writing or
whatever like there's a picture of me as
a 10 year old kid with a Hulk t-shirt
drawing you know so I'm looking at that
every day and just like wow this is
actually I'm playing in this world that
you know I I've played in for so many
years in my head and and and just have
been a fan of and to now walk out of my
trailer onto a Marvel set is is just
crazy for me if I'm you man I would use
the connections now cuz they'll [ __ ]
let you draw a book you know what I'm
saying because they'll be able to market
that and be like from the guy who's on
run away like why not try to jail for
him we've been the artists your whole
life and you've been a fan but like
that's when I when I got a gig in the
industry when they picked
movie one of the first things I did was
I want to get a job in comics and I used
the one to bridge over to the other
you've got an instant end you're part of
the Marvel family man if I'm you I'd
start asking around be like I'd like to
draw a comic kaboom you'd be surprised
how quickly I'd be like okay they know
they can sell they can mark it off that
one more way to like cross promote their
products the book and the show you
should do it may because this is [ __ ]
genius art and thank you legit great
artwork thank you um oh stop what about
you you got anything else Ryan mark yeah
I just I want to know a little bit about
your path to Runaways you know where
where did you grow up
what was the first gig what was the
first big gig like if somebody wants to
go back and say I want to watch this guy
seems smart let me let me dig down the
rabbit hole where else can I find his
face on my boxes on my screen yeah all
right well several years ago I was born
in Washington DC and that's where I got
started and I guess you know I was I was
the king of industrial films in DC which
is you know it was funny oh hi I'm Ryan
sands and today I'm going to talk to you
about diversity here at the United
States Postal Service of the king of
Jasmine I did a whole bunch of get the
kid and a little show called the wire
came to to town up the road in Baltimore
and I got called in like season 1 to be
a jurist help us stand in and I never
know I didn't get to work because of
rain that we couldn't shoot the scene
and I had no idea it just was British I
worked on it so I got cast in season 3
and as a in a recurring role as a cop
and I never worked with Idris and I'd
had no idea he was English until like
after that I saw him on a BBC vampire
show called ultraviolet I'm like wow
he's killing that English accent
but yeah the the wire was like the the
first what season 3 was what season 3 8
Hamsterdam I think that was four that
was four we've seen three of the boys
yeah so season one was season 1 season 2
was at the docks two was the docks
season three was it's a school and was
that stringer bell's season as well like
he made it to four or three Thank You
minute to three spoiler it just doesn't
do the whole run no but that fantastic
guy what was that like man working their
[ __ ] man II was it was a legendary show
that like has produced a lot of talent
behind the camera and in front of the
cameras for other shows you see shows
cherry-pick yeah the wire like crazy
because that cast was so [ __ ]
phenomenal it wasn't a part of it -
Jesus Christ man it was it was so much
fun I mean you would think that we the
wire went to a lot of you know serious
places dark places the material was
weighty at times but I genuinely had a
great time I worked with Seth Gilliam my
partner of Benjamin Bush and Dominick
Lombardo's II bill Fisk kingpins dead
now and and Bill right I think but
anyway yeah it was like we had a lot of
fun and I was just really blessed stuff
I said myself tremendously blessed to be
a part of something that is part of TV
history it's true and something on the
resume where people go oh you were on
the wire yeah I came to town so that was
yeah it was really cool what else mark
you mentioned that you were a fan
growing up yeah what was the what was
that what was your book of choice what
was your [ __ ] go to spider-man yeah
yeah yeah spider-man
I was I was that kid walking into my
parents room asking them is there some
kind of
liquid that I might be able to get my
hands on that if I was to shoot it out
of something it would like kind of
solidify like Ryan's discovered
masturbation all that to yourself kid
they they knew I was I was talking about
webbing when web fluid in cartridges but
yeah was I was that kid with the
underoos and the lunchboxes and all the
whole nine it was all about spider-man
back then do they give you when you're
on a Marvel show do you suddenly get
like the keys to [ __ ] Disney World
and [ __ ] no I haven't gotten him just
yet I think we might have to wait till
last season to stick around that will
give me free Disney tickets Marvel Dave
they've been great man I got to meet
Stan and I had this like little mini
speech prepared for this dude and then
when I saw him all I could just do was
like you know just I couldn't and had
this Marvel shirt on he's like I like
your shirt and so we we took a took a
picture together so that's that pictures
next to that picture of little me and my
Hulk t-shirt drawing and a picture of me
with Stan Lee that kid we're in the hole
sure need an entire lifetime yeah next
to the other guy crazy who created this
what it's just we're too close to
Hollywood Boulevard sudden noises make
me very jumpy all right we good I think
we're good my god damn give it up for
Ryan ladies The Runaways is on Hulu when
you go home
tonight the first three episodes thank
you for this is fantastic man Wow that's
[ __ ] cool that's fine that is very
cool all right so now we're done with
the news we're done with the news folks
now we jump to Q&A and Q&A later gem is
gonna get interesting this week last
week our friend Deacon who works at 4dx
brought in tickets just like he did this
week 40x is a theatre experience they
have it at down at LA live it's when you
watch a movie and you're sitting in a
chair and the chair comes to life so
when you watch like a Marvel movie and
they do the Marvel logo in the beginning
has it turns and [ __ ] your chair
literally let goes like this around the
logo if you're watching the last Jedi
which will be opening soon in a 40x
theater downtown I guess what next month
when the crawl happens your seat goes
back as the crawl is going for it's
[ __ ] spellbinding if it snows in the
movie it snows in the theater if a tire
screeches by you you smell burnt rubber
there's blasts of air it's [ __ ] nuts
it's a wonderful way to watch a movie
it's like going on like it's going on
like The Simpsons Ride the Shrek ride
the Back to the Future ride but if it
was one long move it makes every movie
emotion sim oh yes it's fantastic so
Tekin brought in tickets that were given
away to folks asking questions to a pop
presuming that nobody goes to the movie
by themselves unless you're mark barnard
so what we also have though aside from
those tickets the said Charlie Brown
music now plays you imagine we got some
swag man some cool [ __ ] that nobody
really has out
out of the world okay so I work on the
flash and Supergirl and stuff so he
knows one guy super excited so our man
who I mentioned before our mic of
working as the special effects guy he
oversees everything he's the guy that
like you know anything time you see the
flash run or [ __ ] Supergirl fly or
fight an alien or some such [ __ ] that's
not really there he's the guy that's
kind of like making sure that it's all
there he's also a director on some of
the episodes
anyway he brought me a bunch of [ __ ]
swag he came didn't show the podcast and
so he brought me like some cool ash cool
ash cool ass [ __ ] flashed this right
here it's like a lineup of all the flash
bad guys so it's you know it's got a
king shark
it's got Grodd I think yes Parris say
all the characters that they've kind of
brought to life this is a really cool
last flash shirt that shows flash like
it's the jaws poster but it's flash you
know and King sharks under them and
stuff like that so if you ask a good
question and it's got to be good we're
gonna be judgy as [ __ ] you can't
seriously cuz this is good quality [ __ ]
that we're giving out now and stuff this
is not pass/fail yeah you can't be like
hey what happened to moose jaw's [ __ ]
find out on the internet you gotta keep
it relevant you gotta keep it to the
subject matter it helps if we're both
involved don't direct your questions
just at me and stuff but if your
questions [ __ ] cool enough and it
leads to a cool discussion you will not
only win two tickets to a 40 X cinema
you win the t-shirt of your choice so
there it is think very hard again and
don't get shitty if we're like that
ain't good enough like we may answer it
but it may be not good enough maybe
maybe like I'll be like alright that's
good enough for sure but not tickets or
vice versa and we'll see we'll be
judging but just letting you know in
advance this is the part of the show
where we get really shitty and on a
higher
[Laughter]
jacy's got the microphone because for a
while people were bitching at home hey
we can't hear the [ __ ] questions so
we're gonna make sure that's taken care
of JC you pick the people it's in your
hands go ahead pick the first one
Q&A begins ladies Jonah fat man and
Batman Q&A give us your energy put your
hands together Kevin and Mark seen
Justice League a movie I never thought I
would see in my entire life like let the
six unite wondering what movie would you
really like to see like I would love to
see more of the Fourth World let Taika
Waititi do the New Gods and just blow
the cosmic world away what do you what
would you like to see I'm with you I
mean last week I said I'd loves you a
question movie but now that we're in the
world of the new gods like it was
thrilling to hear him say darkside it
was like I know a lot of people are
[ __ ] on Steppenwolf as a villain
though he's one big CG character but to
me I'm like yeah but that's the doorway
to the fourth world man and like if
you're they showed [ __ ] boom tubes in
the movie dude like that made me so
thrilling they were so [ __ ] many you
almost got tired of him but there was a
time in your life where the only time
you'd ever see a boom tube was on the
page of a comic book maybe in Superman
animated series or something like that
or maybe in the superpowers show way
back in the day when I was when they did
it there for a bit but [ __ ] like that
was like oh my god you can keep going
and space allows you to tell different
stories where you're not just like hey
Batman's there like you can you could go
through DC's rich history and tell other
cool stories you know they went to space
once with Green Lantern didn't work out
for them and now they don't seem
interested in going back but they're
they got a lot of characters that belong
up there so I'm with you man I think
like in going so crazy Jack Kirby deep
and into the fourth world would be fun
to see sadly it's never gonna happen you
I kind of want hitman yeah I got a way
better answer I kind of Garth Ennis
Azure that is in John McCrae John McCrae
I have this series that
was set in the DC universe yeah like
smack-dab in the middle of Tommy man at
Monaghan was a hit man who got
superpowers so he was a little more
advanced but he did [ __ ] like remember
he fought the dog welder the guy who
would just weld dogs to dogs and other
people I remember when he had to fight
zombie baby seals yes which was basing
excuse to show clubbing of baby my book
it is very funny book yeah I would like
to see that's good but I feel like
there's there's a way to help shift the
tonal conversation about DC movies into
a into a place where it doesn't rely so
much on again the stentorian feeling of
just seeing these heroes on screen and
let me have a good time like show me
part of the DC Universe I've never seen
before you know I've been to famous Kira
I've been to Gotham I've been to
Metropolis I've been on the way you're
spoiled though we worship the only [ __ ]
for three movies in a row we only went
to the mascara like once you can't
already be like I'm [ __ ] jaded by the
toilet no no especially with the sequins
in the movie was so [ __ ] thrilling
yeah is the same island oh dude this is
a good point man is my pic hit man is it
next Olympic all right man that's good
enough question you get the tickets and
you want a shirt or a Justice Society of
America Hat Gigantor Oh a big one Oh in
terms of size
I actually I well I have one that's way
too big for you this is a 5 X Punisher
shirt you don't need you could wear that
with three other people
I don't think you want that but could
hold on these are I think their biggest
one is like to excel but trust me well
let trust me it ain't a real to excel
because I pulled it on I heard there's
an excel and you get two tables all
right well done give it up for him all
right JC where we going next microphone
because I can't hear oh sorry
can hear me now not really is there
microphone or is that more just for home
use it is it's for the home all right
hey sorry so all's you shouldn't be
sorry I literally cut you off to talk
technical [ __ ] that's okay these are for
the tickets we got any serious now go
ahead so now that Ben Affleck is
thinking about leaving after two movies
there's some some talks on the
Internet's that possibly Jake Gyllenhaal
could be replacing him the word talks
the Internet today I was sitting around
going who should replace I was wondering
what you guys thought of that as if he
does you know say yes to becoming the
Batman as you know being Jake Gyllenhaal
in all of his Jake Gyllenhaal
I think I've before Jake Gyllenhaal
Batman he wasn't the first guy I thought
of but but why not like I think he could
pull it off I if they're gonna recast
completely I would prefer they go for
Jon Hamm I doubt it'll happen but he
[ __ ] looks like Bruce Wayne and
Batman all at once and he's a hell of an
actor and stuff so III he could pull off
charming and funny he's [ __ ] funny
when he's on SNL and he could pull off
dark we've seen him be Dom Draper you
know dark stuff so I think he'd be a
[ __ ] badass Batman I'd vote for ham
you I'm always about ham
I don't mind jake gyllenhaal like I
think that that he's a very talented
actor and remembering what he looked
like in southpaw you know he got [ __ ]
ripped oh my god that's right he's not
very tall though is he no he's a wee
actor lad it's not a leprechaun are you
sure good have you seen gold I'm trying
to think I have met him like back when I
was working on the Green Hornet movie in
Miramax he was a guy that they really
wanted so they were like watching meat
with Jake Gyllenhaal and if I remember
correctly Jake Gyllenhaal don't want me
to talk about this yeah if I remember
correctly I think I made a mistake I
think he came over and I made a mistake
or maybe I'm mistaking him with Topher
Grace I definitely made that
[ __ ] a steak he came over to
talk about Fletch Gyllenhaal came over
to talk about but he went to the old
office yeah but he was a sweet kid real
good and there he would have been a
great Britt Reid this is long before
Seth Rogen did his version and stuff so
nice kid man I think he could totally
pull and he's right he did get ripped
for southpaw so I guess he couldn't I
Jon Hamm is [ __ ] the perfect Bruce
Wayne I feel like he's a hair too old
though [ __ ] that they keep putting fake
gray into a flex hair like you know
they're trying to age him up take an
age-appropriate guy
my favorite part one of my favorite
parts of Justin League is when you see
him in the you can spot the reshoots
when he goes to Iceland or whatever the
[ __ ] that is because there's toupee is
different
Alex Harris yeah yeah there's there's a
widow's peak and half of those shots and
there's I got swept across on the other
one and it just keeps like a being like
what's happening what is his face weird
I was not looking that close after
studying Superman's live but I've been
I've been a little like sitting through
as much of Punisher as I've been sitting
through was the guy in there who plays
Billy Russo I'm gonna I'm gonna make you
are in your [ __ ] mouth
Ben Barnes is playing
Frank castles former confidante and
compete reott yeah that guy that guy
he's basically playing Bruce Wayne
ultimately who also runs a mercenary
outfit in his in his oh yeah but there's
there's like a sinuous just your warmint
yeah like he's he's a little like he's
got a hair of New York in there but it's
still like you know I could [ __ ] see
that guy and he feels just young enough
that you're not having to hope that he
doesn't like get arthritis going through
the [ __ ] paces which is my fear for
him hammers about as old as Affleck
which is probably older than they want
for the next Batman I think they want to
go young I think they want to go young
if the Batman is going to be a origin
story ish or a year one story is said
more they didn't even said that they
just said more of a detective story
which would be very interesting and wash
they said yeah but I mean Batman Beyond
would be like the obvious choice for for
those of us who were like look you want
to get rid of the old Batman that hasn't
bring in the young Batman is perfect and
and kind of they're doing that with Iron
Man and spider-man right now in
homecoming and stuff but I I don't think
they're gonna listen to us I think they
think that's too like oh that's too deep
cuts but I I think you could totally
pull off a Batman Beyond movie I mean
you get Michael Keaton back is Bruce
Wayne you just shot me with the
nostalgia bullet oh my god yes yes [ __ ]
and then do your crisis movie that's
amazing all right I was good enough
question that generated conversation you
get the ticket pick out one of these
take these tickets meanwhile JC's taking
us somewhere JC take us there
okay oh hey hey hey
you mentioned Justice League and then
she to him do you think for justice big
to or the aspect of Menace do to their
gonna lean towards Man of Steel against
Brainiac or maybe Vandal Savage coming
in taking over that whole Legion of Doom
aspect and creating that whole extra
super
so supervillains and creating that world
do you think that that should be should
be the direction they lead into I I
would I mean look you're talking to a
fan so naturally I'm like put as many
[ __ ] bad guys as the screen as
possible and as many villains and have
them run at each other and it explodes
so I hope so I said earlier I do hope
that they let Henry have his own Man of
Steel movie again like man is steel too
and I do hope it if it was Brainiac
that'd be great but if they wanted to do
Legion of Doom instead I'm all okay for
that smells like they're doing in
Justice League or injustice gang or
something like that I you know I I like
the fact that already they've got two
villainous looking villains sitting
together on a yacht talking Lex Luthor
being bald and [ __ ] Deathstroke
looking like Deathstroke we're really
looking like Deadpool like in the first
scene like as they were behind him on
the boat I was like Deadpool's and this
[ __ ]
it was Deathstroke instead but I'm I'm
yeah that's what I'd like to see them
just go like here's all the [ __ ]
villains like just throw it off the wall
and see what [ __ ] sticks and you
could tell a cool story man like why not
do Grant Morrison's Rock of Ages
storyline which begins as an injustice
gang story and then turns into a
time-traveling [ __ ] epic like that's
if I was gonna pick source material
that's what I'd pick there was a run on
Justice League that Grant Morrison did
it's called Rock of Ages is one of the
greatest comic book stories ever [ __ ]
compiled and ever told and it's you know
now it's a get as a graphic novel but it
involves everybody every League
character all your [ __ ] favorite
villains and [ __ ] all of it [ __ ]
makes sense
I would I would pick that you I I kind
of want a bizarro movie you know like I
think I think Henry Cavill is a better
actor than then I guess the DC Universe
gives them credit for being yeah because
he was wonderful on I used to love the
tutors the tutors yeah he was really
good in man from Hong Kong even though
nobody saw it but me but I think that
that [ __ ] bizarro like give give me
Superman fighting against his own
twisted warped version of himself like
let show me what it's like to see the
The Betrayal of science we saw that it's
Superman 3 fought himself a garbage dump
but [ __ ] like that but you say Henry
would play bizarro as well I think so I
mean that would make up for the fact
that he literally has only add like what
six minutes and Justice League at most
yeah a lot of it involving corn look at
this you smell good did I used to smell
bad [ __ ] you you just got back let's not
bicker yeah I feel like you know
Brainiac I love the idea of Brainiac
movie I love the idea of a Brainiac plus
bizarro movie if I can just bring it
bring it bring it yeah all the villains
honestly and and now we live in an era
where you can get away with the goofiest
[ __ ] costumes you think back to the
first [ __ ] x-men movie and you know
they're all in black and and look and
Logan makes a joke like about like what
do we want to wear expand our yellow
spandex or something we now live in the
world we can get away bless you with all
those [ __ ] outfits the goofier the
[ __ ] better show me a live-action toy
man that'd be [ __ ] amazing so I hope
they lean into that that's what that
last scene felt like and yes it was
definitely a stop to the fans and [ __ ]
but like who's buying these tickets if
not the [ __ ] fans so that like at the
end of the movie gave me hope where I
was like yeah man like now they're gonna
lean into the fun of this [ __ ] as
opposed to like how sad it is to be a
superhero now they're gonna [ __ ] be
like all right they're gonna fight
they're equals it's lits it's the
challenge of the Superfriends
you know the show from when I was a kid
I hope they do it i I don't know what
happens now I mean
Vandal Savage who's an immortal aspect
of it and totally he warps time yeah the
only thing is I'm not a big vandal
savage guy like they did a Mon CW and
I'm like that's enough all right you get
[ __ ] that stuff generate enough
conversation you get some tickets pick
out one of these fine Church JC's gonna
take us to some planet or someone else
hey guys hey so I feel like Marvel
really does diversity great
I feel like DC has it has a long history
of not having it in their comic books
and they're trying to compensate in the
movies how would you fix it in their
movie universe and I don't just mean
black guys how would I fix it well how
would we fix it together like Bob the
Builder yes yes we can I mean like I was
glad cyborg was there but I was puzzled
as to why it wasn't the Jon Stewart
Green Lantern like for 10 years kids
watched that Justice League cartoon and
their Green Lantern was not how Jordan
it was [ __ ] Jon Stewart so it made no
sense to me why they wouldn't just
lanterns of one of the founding members
of League he might as well [ __ ]
include him and stuff but they went with
cyborg which bugged me as traditionalist
cuz I'm like now he's in the Titans you
idiots but they didn't [ __ ] care so
naturally I you know I would start with
Jon Stewart I you know we talked about
an old episode of [ __ ] Batman I'm
Batman
I think Idris Elba would make a
fantastic Bruce Wayne / Batman so if I
was in charge of the universe I would be
like let's [ __ ] do this like you know
I don't know some people would be like
he's too old now [ __ ] it then you do the
old version of them I mean there's also
no reason I mean granted they'd sort of
burned the bridges of Jonah Hex
with that movie there's no reason that
interstellar couldn't be Jonah Hex
either not that you want to mess up that
fun why would you want to watch another
Jonah Hex like we had to sit through it
once man I
there's a world in would you make a
decent Jonah Hex movie if you do it
right and I think that I mean the comic
book is a [ __ ] ton of fun you know I
mean not that you want to just sort of
race Bend every character and the DC
Universe just for diversity's sake
because why is my sense but honestly why
not like in a world where you got to
sell books and you got to move product
and you got to create stories why not
why not just be like hey [ __ ] now
we're doing this for a while and now
we'll flip back and do this like why not
like it would it would sell some books
it would generate conversation granted a
lot of conversation would be like bring
back my old heroes I'm a racist but
still it would generate conversation and
stuff like that I don't know well you
know I think there's you know
incorporating the milestone universe and
to DC proper sort of helps out a little
bit I would watch a static shock movie
tomorrow if you told me there was gonna
be one I mean I did you say way way way
watch static show I mean there there
there are times when race bending works
there are times when it doesn't work I
mean as much as I love a Giselle but I
feel like Bruce Wayne is an
intrinsically Caucasian concept because
ooh
discuss interesting as [ __ ] because the
Wayne family is old money like real old
money like Carnegie old money and there
is no black Carnegie there is no
generations of black wealth that you can
live off of there's no hereditary Butler
in that way you know it is it is the it
is the idol dream of the legacy rich is
what Batman is and be guilt that you
feel that your family feels after having
been muscled in the bosom of a place
like Gotham and watched it go to [ __ ]
and so I'm going to do something because
my dad was a doctor didn't have to be a
doctor [ __ ] riches [ __ ] you know like
what the side street back when I was a
kid I thought that's where he goes money
I was it [ __ ] those doctors loot
but yeah he was a dilettante he didn't
his dad didn't have to be at the doctor
chose me doctor dude they were rich
either way you know like a crazy rich
it's super rich like again like you're
right I never rich from England rich so
I don't feel like that lends itself as
well to to the african-american story to
the story of black people in America
suddenly finding themselves with too
much [ __ ] money so much my Oh like
let's fight crime in a costume that's
that sick money that's sick month that's
bored like like even Oprah doesn't do
[ __ ] like that and she's got the most
money yeah you know so like I feel like
you can you can do that as long as it
makes sense within the context of what
the character is supposed to be you know
like I don't have a problem with you
know the ancient one being Tibetan or
technically when the ancient one being
Nigerian or the ancient one being
whatever like every hundred years you
get a new ancient one make it a
different one that's why I didn't have
the biggest problem in the world would
tilda swinton
you know as long as you told me I know
we're gonna cycle this one out because
the next one is gonna be a fat Buddhist
from someplace else cool
I'm on board you know like it is if it
has to make some kind of internal sense
to do it but I think that the real
diversity comes when you create new
characters when you empower creators to
bring something new to what is a
eighty-year-old universe and say hey
like you do yo Gosar's [ __ ] off so i'm
they're not asking me yeah but I mean if
you're if if you're a comic book company
then your job should be to talk to as
many people as you can to open the doors
whose many creators as you can so that
you can get a plurality of opinions that
you can get a diversity of perspectives
and that will always make the books a
little bit better and ultimately will
always make you more money you know
that's the part that I never quite
understand that they don't understand is
that diversity is a engine for economic
growth and if you're if you're
perilously clinging on to an outmoded
publishing model then you need as many
[ __ ] legs up as you can get so try it
what's the worst that can happen you're
gonna have books that don't sell you
already have books that don't sell
you know now they're gonna be
interesting books that don't sell you
know and now there's gonna be some kids
somewhere who reads that book and it's
like aw [ __ ] I didn't know that I could
do this or I didn't know that I was
represented here maybe I'm gonna make a
comic book and then I'm saying all that
good [ __ ] never gonna homes like I can't
here up turn it up turn it up but that's
I mean ultimately it's it's less about
how we fix diversity because we're old
men who nobody's asking how to fix
diversity except for you thank you very
much that's adorable look I tried to fix
Batman but mark thinks he needs to be a
white guy so there the black guy said he
needs to be really good thing I'm like
oh my god you're right but yeah like it
ultimately happens by the people who
signed the checks and Hulu greenlight
the books and who should be forced in
one way or another to interview more
than the people they already know
did you I'm sorry this is off topic but
did you watch that live this weekend
yeah
did you see the Batman sketch so they
did a sketch like where you know Bruce
Wayne opens his house up for
Thanksgiving or whatever so
underprivileged people are coming
through the house and stuff and
everybody keeps talking about Batman
about how violent Batman is like he
broke my [ __ ] jaw like you know I was
jaywalking or something out of my trunk
people keep coming in they're going you
guys talk about Batman he's again he's
like he's so hard and they tell stories
about unnecessary roughness and Batman's
there Bruce Wayne's there and he's like
well I'm sure he means well like I'm
pretty sure he beats up people look just
like us that's a really funny [ __ ]
skin but yeah I mean it's yeah it's not
for us to fix diversity it's for other
people to do so but us to just sort of
remind folks that it's it's the best
possible decision you can make is to is
to incorporate more voices and that less
tickets you won tickets and a shirt
come grab a shirt you how about alright
take a hat Justice Society huh
sure alright JC we got one set tickets
left one question left and I'll show is
that an ad no pressure
I know pick a good one JC I love Bernie
Wrightson I mean he really influenced me
as an artist growing up
Bernie Wrightson yes and you Rodin I
really liked your version of Swamp Thing
so talking about moving away from the
usual superhero things you have this
like house of Secrets house of mystery
all this other material that's not
Marvel related so you're not going
head-to-head with Marvel not capes not
superheroes necessarily this really rich
yes so the question is how about that
great idea
that is alright well let's talk about
that house of secret DC for years did
more than just superheroes capes and
stuff they got a rich legacy of non
superhero characters a lot of them got
scalped up by the vertigo universe so
let's use the vertigo universe as an
example if you want to tell a story that
Marvel can't tell tell the Sandman like
that's the story they've been trying to
do for [ __ ] years and that's a comic
book story straight out there universe
tell the Swamp Thing like tell of smart
version of The Swamp Thing not not that
the West Craven version was done but it
was definitely more rubber suits and
stuff but you know now with special
effects you can grow that guy used to be
like you know somebody had to wear a
rubber suit but now you could do the hem
forming out of the [ __ ] ground and
stuff so yeah lean into that I guess I'm
all for that but you know obviously I'm
not in charge will it work could it work
I think so why not like well told story
should work period and in a world where
you're right like the moment they put
suits on they're competing against you
know Marvel on some level because it's
just superhero storytelling maybe try to
tell a superhero story like the way Fox
seems to be doing the new
mutants trailer doesn't look like a
superhero movie looks like a horror
movie so you know maybe DC should be
doing Swamp Thing or doing some of the
darker [ __ ] you know Hellblazer or
something like that mark yeah that means
you get tickets man you want tickets to
this thing come on up and pick out a
shirt how adorable you sent a runner
wait take a shirt - man take a shirt
runner come back what hoes from the
front making you work out like crazy
there's there's this pick one I know
yeah they're they're sexy sizes to be
honest with you
four that's why I brought him in I was
like I'll never fit in any of these
there was one extra small that I was
like Jesus there you go there it is give
it up for the ladies is there anything
else we want to cover I got nothing man
you're empty at this point I am tapped
you didn't want what do you mean you got
tickets but you didn't get a shirt yeah
sure looks you with a [ __ ] gun show
in town look in the extra small yeah but
what's it show up the guns
give it up firm we got a shirt all right
folks
have you had a good time this evening I
was real worried man that we were you
know the Justice League [ __ ] was gonna
be depressing but it's actually kind of
hopeful I thought you're gonna go harder
against it than you did I'm glad you did
I thought it was gonna be like you know
like an another [ __ ] thing before we
get out of here though let's talk comic
books real quick I got set this big box
this week in the in the mail the post
ladies and gentlemen or that pancakes
yes it is
the Doomsday Clock box the Doomsday
Clock comic book written by Geoff Johns
published by DC is supposed to bring
together the DC Universe as we know it
and the Watchmen universe The Watchmen
character is going to be incorporated
into the DC Universe some people find
this controversial because Alan Moore
wants nothing to do with DC or whatever
you know some people feel like hey man
they're comic book characters DC owns
them they should be able to do what they
want i I don't know where I stand on the
the scale of things I love the Watchmen
by Alan Moore and and Dave Gibbons but
at the same time it's such a great
concept you could keep [ __ ] telling
stories and stuff and the idea of like
oh my god those cats like interacting
with Batman of Superman is kind of
thrilling so they sent this out this
week it came with a comic book issue one
of Doomsday Clock but it also came with
Joe's pancake mix and they also sent it
out with a little hundred percent pure
maple syrup and then there's this it's a
pin and it's the Doomsday Clock with the
Superman S at the top and of course like
I said issue one of doomsday clocks so a
really sweet package in this letter that
explains [ __ ] that says you know what it
all is it's a new 12 issue graphic story
from Geoff Johns and Gary Frank looks
phenomenal
like the art of course Gary Frank it's
it's beautiful Geoff Johns and arguably
one of the greatest comic book writers
of all time and stuff so it's in really
good hands this is a cool thing but I'll
be honest with the kids at my house it
will get piled under a bunch of other
[ __ ] and I'll discover it rediscover it
in five years ago like oh what is this
so rather than that
but I guarantee you there's somebody out
there there's a big DC Comics fan in
this room who is it well your hand what
a [ __ ] fast what is it you got dude
shut up now you're wearing a fat man
sure but you already got tickets and the
thing but he's got a shirt and he's also
got the cap you [ __ ] one sit down
dude [ __ ] greedy greedy greedy my man
came with my [ __ ] do you read DC Comics
you go every week to the comic store do
you give a [ __ ] about this but do you
like really give a [ __ ] about it or do
you just want pancakes where do you just
yeah if you want pancakes moves are done
by the my Schneider and their thing and
what's the name mom and I got a brain
for it Flash's father plays as flashes
you know he's he's also the doctor been
added Mickey blue man yes yeah I had
this theory that they might try bringing
in you know that way you know but
because it's kind of coincidental he's
playing the same part yeah yes waiting
for this kind of stuff to go in I've
been waiting and watching this stuff for
a long time ever since covered the
button in the cage alright when the
comic are ya man [ __ ] there it is
didn't you you win it it goes home with
a fan and stuff alright anything else
from you my friend no I didn't come
bringing pancakes
so I'm flat out I wasn't told this was
that the HomeGoods part of the show this
is my favorite part of the show now's
when we do Q&A cuz like I got I get so
much stuff that it's like I can give it
away like and it's cool [ __ ] like those
plaid shirts are badass
you can't get those out in the world you
can only get them if like you worked on
the show so I'm like I got all this [ __ ]
at home like I got copies of the shirts
that I give out whenever I do episodes
when I direct episodes like Supergirl
shorts and flash shirts so I was like I
should stop bring them in give them out
during the [ __ ] Q&A and stuff
everybody asks a question yeah it's
funny they get a chance like door prizes
and [ __ ] like that but I do that because
I enjoy the [ __ ] adda doing the show
it's [ __ ] fun I love the casual
format I love being here at scum and
villainy it's a great place to do the
[ __ ] show people getting a drink and
it's not very often like you go to a bar
get [ __ ] drunk and geek out you know
what I'm saying like nobody fights
there's never been any problems and [ __ ]
it's a real good vibe to this show doing
it right here so I don't know anything
for me to make it better makes me
happier about the whole thing and giving
out [ __ ] you're in the queue now and
just makes me happy
yeah we couldn't have done it though
without deacon and the folks at 40x give
it up for the 4dx theater down at LA
alive and that's about all the time we
have for the show this week ladies and
gentlemen for fat man on Batman I've
been Kevin Smith I've been mark barnard
tune in next episode which is we're
shooting here next week on Monday yeah
27th we'll be back here on the 27th
which i think is next week yes it is and
yes until then happy Thanksgiving ladies
gentlemen for found out and I'm Kevin
Smith I'm up another tune in next time
same bat-time same bat-channel smart
guess that got more youtube.com/ so it's
Kevin smooth thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you